j'ai fait deux opérations donc en 2019
j'ai fait une liposuccion et en même
temps on avait fait une bichette parce
que j'avais de la graisse
qu'on a des excès de graisse dans les
joues souvent les présentateurs télé
tout ça ils le font ah oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai un peu les jeux
en novembre j'ai fait une liposuccion
donc du ventre du dos et j'ai fait une
gynéco mastie comme Benjamin Castaldi il
l'a fait un excès de graisse qu'on a
donc dans les pectoraux d'accord et donc
comment tu as vu ça toi alors bah parce
que j'avais des l'impression d'avoir des
seins en fait non mais là on la voit
beaucoup là
ils m'ont mis 500 g dans chaque
pectoraux à 500 g on délocalise
exactement la graisse et la glace dans
chaque pectoraux de 500 ouais c'est ça
vous voulez voir